jetzt bei achtung verhandlungen einer
der rätselhaftesten kriminalfälle
deutschland steht vor der aufklärung im
april 1995 verschwindet sonja
engelbrecht in der münchner innenstadt
spurlos bis zuletzt hofften ihre eltern
dass ihre sonja noch leben könnte doch
jetzt machten die ermittler einen
düsteren fund der oberschenkelknochen
von sonja engelbrecht aktuell durch
diese auffindesituation muss man davon
ausgehen dass irgendwo hier im endeffekt
in der nähe auch noch andere teile des
gesetzes sind oder auch das gesamte
skelett wurde sie ermordet und war etwa
ein serienmörder am werk dieser frage
der gehen wir jetzt hier nach
und damit willkommen zur achtung
fahndungen mein name ist maximilian
kiewel und wir beginnen heute mit diesem
fall polizisten durchkämmten ein
waldstück zwischen münchen und nürnberg
drehen wirklich jeden stein um sie
wollen ein mord rätsel lösen das im
april 1995 mitten in münchen begann
damals verschwand die 19 jährige sonja
engelbrecht und jetzt 26 jahre später
steht dieser unheimliche fall
tatsächlich vor der auflösung karl heim
und willi von der osten wissen warum
wundert schafften durchkämmen den wald
stochern im dickicht suchen nach
antworten auf den rätselhaften
knochenfund ein waldarbeiter findet in
einem wald knochen und wie sich
herausstellt handelte es sich um einen
menschlichen oberschenkelknochen durch
eine dna verfahren konnte er der seit 26
jahren vermissten sonja engelbrecht
zugeordnet werden am 11 april 1995
verschwindet die damals 19 jährige
spurlos zuvor ist sonja in der münchner
innenstadt unterwegs geht in eine bar
feiert mit freunden um zwei uhr nachts
macht sie sich mit einem freund auf den
weg nach hause am münchner
stiglmaierplatz trennen sie sich denn
sonja möchte sich plötzlich von ihrer
schwester mit dem auto abholen lassen
will diese aus einer telefonzelle
anrufen und verabschiedet sich von ihrem
freund er ist der letzte der sonja leben
ziehen wird ihr freund robert der ist
gegen zwei uhr 28 in eine tram
eingestiegen die ihnen nach hause
gefahren hat das telefon ihrer schwester
hat allerdings nie geklingelt man geht
davon aus dass sonja in ein auto
gestiegen ist entweder freiwillig oder
gezwungen auf jeden fall danach verliert
sich ihre spur
sonjas familie gab die hoffnung nie auf
sie glaubten bis zuletzt darin gutes
ende sondern als vater ist inzwischen
verstorben der durchbruch in den
ermittlungen bringt nun für mutter
ingrid und schwester silvia die traurige
gewissheit der vor einem jahr gefundene
oberschenkelknochen ist von sonja
engelbrecht
entdeckt in einem waldstück 100
kilometer vom ort entfernt an dem sie
zuletzt gesehen wird was ist mit sonja
in der nacht zum 11 april passiert wie
sind ihre knochen in den wald gekommen
wurde die damals 19 jährige ermordet
mysteriös zwei weitere frauen
verschwinden in den 90er jahren in
münchen die 28 jährige kanadierin
christina verschwindet 1991 zuletzt
wurde sie in einem restaurant gesehen
kurz danach wird ihr abgetrenntes bein
in einem wald gefunden und auch von
kranken schwester bettina trapp hat viel
zeit 1997 jede spur die fälle sind bis
heute ungelöst wurden alle drei frauen
opfer eines serienkillers
seit tagen durchkämmt die polizei jetzt
den wald mehr als 140 beamte sind im
einsatz setzen spürhunde ein auf der
suche nach hinweisen zu diesem
mysteriösen cold case und weiteren
knochen von sonja engelbrecht aktuell
durch diese auffindesituation muss man
davon ausgehen dass irgendwo hier im
endeffekt in der nähe auch noch andere
teile des gesetzes sind oder auch das
gesamte skelett liegen momentan
zumindest davon aus und wollen das auf
keinen fall ausschließen und
entsprechend werden hier auch die
suchmaßnahmen weiterlaufen bisher jedoch
erfolglos sonjas verschwinden und ihr
tod bleiben auch nach 26 jahren noch ein
rätsel doch noch ist die akte
engelbrecht nicht geschlossen ja und
über diesen fall wollen wir weiter
sprechen mit dr constantinis die bei uns
ist rechtsmedizinerin an der uniklinik
frankfurt guten abend sie haben einen
oberschenkelknochen für uns mitgebracht
denn über den wollen wir sprechen weil
er so wichtig ist in diesem fall sagen
sie es einmal was ist das besondere am
oberschenkelknochen wie unterscheidet er
sich von den anderen knochen zunächst
ist der oberschenkelknochen der größte
und auch schwerste knochen in unserem
körper und der oberschenkelknochen ist
wie alle extremitäten knochen ein
röhrenknochen das heißt zeichnet sich
durch einen schaft und durch zwei gelenk
bildende anteile aus wir haben das
kniegelenk und da oben das hüftgelenk
das heißt man kann ihn eigentlich mit
ein bisschen erfahrung ganz gut einem
oberschenkel zu ordnen und natürlich
auch einen menschen zuordnen im
gegensatz zu einem tierischen knochen
was ja eigentlich die erste frage ist
wenn knochen gefunden werden es ist
menschlicher oder tierischer herkunft
das heißt wenn man ganzen knochen hat
dann kann man schon jede menge daran
ablesen jetzt an diesem her sieht man
glaube ich auch dass er besonders groß
ist das heißt er gehört auch zu einem
großen menschen und man erkennt er ist
robust und hat hier diese sehr
hervortretenden muskel ansatzstellen das
heißt es wird sich mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit um den männlichen
knochen handeln und wenn man uns die
gelenkflächen hier angucken die sind
schön glatt das heißt es wir haben wenig
verschleiß es wird wohl am ehesten an
eher jüngerer mensch gewesen sein das
heißt innerhalb kurzer zeit mit
entsprechend expertise und bisschen
erfahrung kann man sagen das ist auf
jeden fall ein menschlicher
oberschenkelknochen von einem mann
wahrscheinlich jüngeren alters in dem
fall den wir gerade gesehen haben dann
mehr gehört es ist also dna an diesen
knochen sichergestellt worden und die am
ende sondern engelbrecht zugeordnet
worden wo und wie finde ich denn an
diesen knochen dna der ganze knochen ist
eigentlich voll von den armen könnte
sich bei so einem robusten stabilen und
intakten knochen an jeder stelle des
knochens die dna nehmen vielleicht am
einfachsten hier im schaft bereich man
muss nur darauf achten dass von außen
keine kontaminationen dran kommt man
wird also ein bisschen abschaben und
dann mit einem kleinen bohrer das
material aus der tiefe gewinnen wenn sie
jetzt hören ein einzelner
oberschenkelknochen ist gefunden worden
mit all ihrer erfahrung spricht dass er
für eine natürliche todesursache oder
eher für ein gewaltverbrechen
naja also wäre es handelt sich um eine
junge person 19 jährige frau die nach
allem was man weiß gesund ist und wir
wissen dass junge gesunde menschen ich
plötzlich und unerwartet verstorben und
schon gar nicht dass sie unbeobachtet
versterben oder nicht aufgefunden werden
es gibt schon den plötzlichen herztod
bei sehr jungen leuten liegen dann meist
tot im bett und werden dann in ihrer
üblichen umgebung angetroffen oder man
versteht wie zb beim sport aber dass
jemand nicht aufgefunden wird und
plötzlich verstirbt ist absolut eine
absolute rarität das heißt junge leute
die gesund sind die sterben eines nicht
natürlichen todes üblicherweise da kommt
natürlich zum einen suizid oder unfall
in betracht aber jetzt gerade in diesem
speziellen fall an auch ein verschwinden
ohne dass man eine spur hat spricht
wenig für einen suizid das heißt es
würde spricht alles dafür dass hier ein
gewaltverbrechen verübt worden ist von
iris ich sage schon mal vielen vielen
dank aber sie bleiben heute bei uns denn
wir reden nachher nochmal über einen
anderen fall gemeinsam den dank an der
stelle schon mal ja und die polizei die
fahndet im fall sonja engelbrecht weiter
und möchte wissen haben sie in münchen
in der nacht vom 10 04 auf den 11 04
1995 sonja gesehen und wer hat ab dem 11
10 495 beobachtungen in dem waldgebiet
zwischen kipfenberg und fahl dorf
gemacht hinweise an die kripo unter der
telefonnummer 089 2910 0